what do you think should happen to the
guy like let's say if you have to choose
any punishment Lord what would you
choose on me you have to suffer I don't
want quick
I personally died in Terror
and I want that person to suffer
I want that person to suffer so you
don't believe in an eye for an eye
you're gonna yo no I'm thinking a whole
[__] we've now learned the identity of
the American Tourist killed while on
vacation at a popular destination in
Germany the woman is 21 year old Eva Lou
Who just last month graduated from the
University of Illinois with both a
bachelor and master of computer science
she was ready to start a job at
Microsoft and went to Germany for a
graduation trip authorities say she and
her friend fellow University of Illinois
grad Kelsey Chang were lured to a
Lookout Point with a spectacular view of
Neuschwanstein Castle a famous 19th
century Bavarian Palace it was also
featured in the 1968 musical Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang authorities arrested
this 30-year-old American who they say
attempted to sexually assault evalu
before pushing both women
165 feet off a cliff Lou docked from
injuries suffered in the fall her friend
survived off a cliff lewd from injuries
suffering
foreign
no I don't think no no
actually Dave Spencer is live with more
on the man behind this attack Dave
yeah some disturbing details in this one
an international crime as you mentioned
and we're learning that the person being
led away seen on video by German police
is right here in Metro Detroit
neighborhood we went looking for the
family of this man seen here being led
away in handcuffs in Germany this
following the death of Eva Lou from
Illinois who was allegedly sexually
assaulted on a trail near newy which
Steen Castle in southern Germany then
pushed from a Scenic Overlook into a
Gorge
165 feet below
you know you hear the numbers but once
they Pan the camera down no because
listen that's a [__] thing
cause I saw that [__]
you have the time to realize what the
[__] is happening to you that is [__]
that is a long fall
the other girl survived but you have to
imagine she probably ain't gonna have
much working
160 feet you'll be lock key to even
being in a wheelchair
Jesus Christ
who's the dude
some guy from Detroit where we're gonna
do a show
let's watch it please
please German police tell Fox News a
second woman Kelsey Chang a friend of
Lou tried to help that friend and was
also pushed off the same ledge landing
on a tree and surviving the arrest of a
suspect made headlines around the world
then came news that he was from Lincoln
Park and when we knocked on his door
yeah we'll move
we'll move it up you have anything to
say about the alligator
hides every story
nothing that person was identified as
the sister of the suspect since he
hasn't been named in a German Court we
aren't using his name either but
neighbors we spoke with say they indeed
live next to the person seen here taken
into custody I thought no no no no no no
he can't that can't be next door this
neighbor says the 30 year old suspect
lives with his brother they seem like a
very good family very quiet the boys are
always quiet they don't bother anybody
and the two typically kept to themselves
especially the 30 year old he's never
spoke to me or anything like that but it
still shocks me she says she can't
remember seeing the suspect's car in the
driveway for some time and says
according to the brother they would
often travel for work he went he went a
lot but I don't know where
I mean
truth is most people don't know their
neighbors
so you being shocked doesn't really mean
anything because you didn't know the
person so it's nothing to really be that
shocked about I guess it's not going to
be that close to someone who's capable
there's some people that know people in
their family did some [__] up [__] and
they wouldn't know that yeah because
yeah because yeah literally if you're a
predator you're not going to be like hey
Neighbors
I love little kids right you're just
going to do it in silence right because
people who are married to whole
Predators yeah and they only find out
when the person gets arrested so yeah
basically this guy try to get these
women said I'll show you the sights and
when they were up there try to get it on
with them they said no and he pushed
them off the ledge
as a reality for some ladies out there
you know what I'm saying why
that is [__] up there's some people
who don't know how to accept no
they'll lose it that's [__] up imagine
you're graduating you're just going
there to see the sights some guys making
a move on you that you never invited and
his response is death
what do you think should happen to the
guy like let's say if you have to choose
any punishment Lord what would you
choose on me you have to suffer
I don't want quick death
and I want that person to suffer
I want that person to suffer
every the fall everything so you want to
push them off the bridge too ah no no
that's not enough no you know what it
should be it should be every family
member of hers who wants to get support
one hand on his back they put him right
on the edge of the original and just
toss the boy off I think that's pretty
good I think that's pretty good I think
if you do something that evil to
somebody you should suffer the exact
same fate done to you a little bit more
because she didn't ask anything
because you're getting that punishment
because you did something she got that
punishment because she did nothing
no you need to suffer more sorry you you
need to suffer more you need to suffer
10 times that she had that punishment
because she did nothing you're gonna get
your punishment because you did
something wrong no you're not going to
do you're not gonna get the same thing
no no you're gonna get worse so you
don't believe in an eye for an eye
you're gonna yo no I'm taking a whole
[__]
I'm thinking the whole [__] especially
if the person didn't do nothing now I
got to lose an eye you get to lose an
eye cause I lost not
I lost tonight I didn't do [__] and then
you're gonna get the same the same
prison as I did with no my punishment
for not doing [__] with me losing an eye
you did some [__] you lose an eye and
you lose something else all right no
we're we're making you suffer no no no
no no no no we're not doing you're
suffering I do not believe in Revenge I
don't believe in any retribution
I believe in a justice system cool
that's not your conversation get the
[__] out of here then you should suffer
you should suffer I hope they get you
I really do don't wish by the puppy shut
the [__] up
yeah she got that because she didn't do
nothing now you're gonna get that and
then some suffer oh yes oh
yes suffer I'm good now I'm good
I don't know I heard this story I just
thought like
what a terrible way to die what terrible
and unnecessary circumstance to die in
and that's the thing that sucks about
life in a lot of ways is that sometimes
you can do everything right and it still
don't go well
and that's what it was in this situation
before you guys go out there and try to
have someone in your life
check your ego
I'm talking for the guys and girls out
there
but the guys particularly because
when things pop off we get violent
check your ego
you have to go out there and learn to
receive a no you're not entitled to
you're not entitled to Friendship you're
not entitled to none of that
relationship we going on tour we coming
to cities near you we want to see you
[__] face to face where you at
we gonna be doing shows awesome well
this summer we're doing three shows
we're doing Detroit Pittsburgh and
Washington DC but afterwards we were
going to England we're going to be going
all across America Asia so if you want
to get tickets make sure you guys go to
the website all right put your name so
we can email you as soon as those
tickets come out for your area we won't
bombard you with nothing else okay I
promise
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna do
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys it's not
because you give that you get I
understand there's expectation
expectation there
but the moment you hear a no dip I'm
trying to push dip
to know
some of y'all got to learn that
it's not for you I got fortunate enough
that for somehow somehow somewhere I
thought I was an ugly kid and I could
never
talk to people and everything and stuff
and I think it's it saved me a lot of
trouble my self-esteem was not that high
so I really thought that I was not for
me
I cannot walk up to you know a woman
would never want me when I was a kid
that's what I was so talking a certain
way to school girls or doing that that
was not me learn to receive a No Other
Women struggle like you know I say men
got the issues and Men got their dangers
that they got a face out there for women
especially when they traveling this is
one of theirs and it's real
best believe I can travel that same
destination 100 times at 100 and nothing
like that ever gonna come closer
happening to me but for women that's not
the case well when they travel they have
a real worry
right and um I don't know it's just one
of those things where when you think to
your family members the people close to
you people you care about and knowing
that they got a struggle with something
like this just because some dudes
want some sexual gratification they want
somebody to touch them like yo listen
let me just ain't easy
that's what you got to deal with but a
girl saying no and you throw them off a
bridge that's [__] up you don't belong
in society no ever although it's fine to
say that [__] upsets you it's fine to be
bothered by it what you don't get to do
is externalize that and be violent
against people like you go into jail
good and unfortunately none of that's
going to be restitutional for the people
who lost her
so yeah it's it's what you wanted but
it's kind of bad is how what you wanted
versus the action that you did because
you didn't get that
the proportion is
messed up you want to push
so that person desires to die because
you said you are get this man out of
here yeah you want to push now you're
going to jail you're gonna get dick
congratulations you played yourself now
you're going to become Buffy
yeah somebody about to bust that [__]
open yep yep crack Hey listen Darwin
Award that goes to you brother that's
another kind of award because Darwin is
is uh when you die
this one is a Jenna Jameson award
because you're gonna get [__]
um that's potato brain um and I'm not
even mad I don't have that I don't have
I don't have that kind of sympathy I
have a lot of sympathy for a lot of
different that
nope that's not me that's not me papi
yeah good luck with that I do think it
is kind of weird how the cameras run up
on the sister like she got something to
do with it or like she can yeah but that
that's that's that's what that's what
they do that's the news I know I know
it's what they do it doesn't mean it's
okay it's like that girl it's not it's
not it's not he did something
then you guys start harassing the family
who they are probably dealing with the
trauma and shock of finding someone in
their own families engaging criminal
Behavior I don't rock with news stations
who want to scoop so badly they run in
the address like if you have a comment
you have a comment it's like yo stay the
[__] away and you know damn well they
don't have any comments what the [__] do
you want that sister the dude to say I
mean they probably say some [__]
generally like oh he wasn't guilty or I
don't know we're generally shocked by
this it's sad what the [__] do you want
the person to say yeah you know it
doesn't add anything to the story your
story was already good you had all the
facts you had the shark value you had
the facts this little bit when you talk
to the sister that's a little bit much
you a bit of a [__] for that but and
she said she don't want to talk you keep
it pushing but you sitting there with
the camera pointing and recording her
while she doesn't want to be on camera
like that's weird to me it's like this
girl died because she didn't want to do
something and this guy did whatever he
did and then to another degree this girl
don't want to talk to you and you keep
talking to her yeah
I'm not saying it's the same thing
but that's it for today's video I know
it's a bit of a dark one but I feel like
I wanted to cover it
um traveling is different travel is
different for both genders I know it for
me as a man I'm still aware when I
travel to certain places
um but I think for women there's like
keenly aware of also just the fact that
men aggress them that's just a fact
um it's like as a lady you're already
physically vulnerable
because you're weaker
in general
and then a dude approaches you and
you're not interested maybe you got a
partner maybe you're not don't want it
doesn't matter what you're not
interested yeah and then you die
because you're not interested
listen
that's why I tell y'all every day
if I had to choose what gender I was
born with every single time I choose a
man does it it honestly I don't care
what nobody says when it comes to
periods of this stuff I'm like that's
just [__] I don't want to deal with I'll
deal with everything and the struggles
of being a man every [__] day of the
week before I deal with this kind of
[__] that's me
um this story is very dark sorry about
that and if you want to entertain
yourself we're going to be in the Jordan
26. okay piece of [__] yeah
hey I'm trying to suit their pain you
just trying to